on the Bachelorette for some reason we
were in Virginia where Chris went crazy
this is crazy and Lincoln went home it's
time for roses and rose eh
hi everybody i'm lauren zima welcome to
our recap of Bachelorette becca kufran
season we're in Virginia why why Wow no
offense to Virginia you guys but oh my
gosh am I ready for something to look at
just something visually tasty whether
it's a cool date in an exotic location
or just I don't know a celebrity that's
not Wayne Newton anything really these
dates are making me feel dated like my
body is dated like I'm dying because I'm
not enjoying them what do you guys think
are the dates living up to your
expectations do you want more from them
please let me know in the comments and
let me know what types of dates you'd
want to see on the show because I get
that there's been a lot of seasons and
that they need to get new ideas maybe
maybe it feels like everything has been
done before help also everyone yes this
week I am NOT drinking rose day I have
an absolutely massive glass of water
because I had an allergic reaction over
the weekend and now I'm on steroids so I
can't drink alcohol but I'm gonna be
healthy because we've got to revitalize
the life of this show mmm life is full
of surprises
Becca okay we start off and Colton's in
another hoodie don't drink every time
you see Colton and a hoodie because
that's a most dangerous game which I
might be willing to play because I'm so
bored I'm sorry I'm saying it but it's
true I don't want to be anyway
we begin with Chris and Lincoln arguing
because the season is all about boys
bickering and after last season Becca
needs a man I'm over it nice no bigger
the one-on-one this week or even a
two-on-one that's what I want the most
and I hope it have you wanted two on one
over on 101 Chris and Lincoln are
bickering because Chris says that he
wants another one-on-one or to be in on
a two-on-one and as much as I dislike
Lincoln for what he's done
Lincoln says you're not gonna get
another one-on-one after getting one
those just aren't the odds and chris
says yes dozens of seasons of this show
that's how the formula works you just
bodysuit and then they get into a body
shaming discussion and then I look away
for one second on the show and I don't
know what's happening Becca and Jason
who I like at least he's funny are on a
date where they're doing some kind of
gothic dancing on a rug in the middle of
a town square
I think wouldn't we I think when we
started this episode Becca said
something about combining the old and
the new why are we in Virginia no
offense to Virginia I just want to be
somewhere colorful with blue skies and
tasty settings and I don't know a cool
hotel something okay so I also can't
figure out the weather in Virginia Becca
is dressed like she's about to hit a
snow storm and Jason has holes in the
back of his jacket she's wearing a vest
and a coat and he's barely wearing a
sweater and then you know because the
dates are just gonna keep on keeping on
we go into a crowded bar I guess we
couldn't shut the bar down and Jason's
friends are there why we never know
their names we don't really see any
significant discussion that happens with
them why did we pay to fly Jason's
friends to Richmond Virginia to get
happy hour I don't know but I liked
Jason's reaction to meeting them that
was cute
it was sweet but I just need
something okay so they have a dinner
date and they opened up to each other
and it's nice and then they go on a
group date and Becca says that they're
here to brush up on your country to
brush up on American history and let's
be honest we all need that it's been a
minute for me although as much as I
don't think I know what I'm talking
about why does this George Washington
have brown hair wasn't it always white I
don't when I picture it's like a picture
of George Washington or painting I guess
it's white hair get the wig color right
so the guys are all in suits and Chris
is calling Lincoln and speak and a lot
and look I'm not saying that Chris is
wrong because now we know about
Lincoln's criminal history but Chris is
acting real wonky himself okay man up
everybody and Blake's face here we
haven't seen much of Blake lately what
his face here says it all he's just like
same Blake same so they've brushed up on
history and now they're going to go into
a debate because it's the Beck election
what exactly is this political process
this is actually you know what it's
sounding a lot like America now very
confusing times within the government
and everyone is contentious and that's
what we're getting into so you know what
maybe I'm wrong maybe they're dead on
because I don't know what's happening
we're debating for who's gonna be
elected to Becca I don't know hello
gentlemen
my name is Ralph mother and I'm the
governor okay in the real governor of
the Commonwealth of Virginia is here and
speaking to how little I know my history
I don't know why Virginia is a
Commonwealth you guys let me know in the
comments is that the same as the state I
don't know I guess I'll google it
so they're debating and what I also
don't understand is that the debate
seems to be them just like answering
questions what is your idea of the
perfect date with Becca but not debate
it's a non debate debates they're it's
more of a QA kolten has asked a question
and his answer is Virginia is for lovers
so I would probably want to take her to
a dog park here what no you lose off the
stage and now Blake gets asked a totally
different question how is this a debate
it's a non debate debate and you know
what now it's time for our next episode
of on the journey with JC where JC is
going to reenact for us the non debate
debate JC thank you for being here with
us and for Manning up and for dressing
well and appropriately for work and here
in the non debate I'm gonna ask you some
really hard-hitting questions in the
style of this group date question one
what is your favorite color
mmm blue well the answer was red
question two what do you like about
dinner the napkins yeah the answer was
plates
Raj see here's your chance to redeem
yourself on the journey for your final
question what do you like about Becca's
men oh well after everything Beck has
been through last season with he was not
be named I kind of thought she'd get a
higher level of guy not so much of the
plane and like the mud and shouting and
schoolyard bullying I thought that some
people would want to step up and take
care of Becca Thank You JC and Jacy
brings us to our next point which is
that the debate does then become a
debate but only so that the men can
squabble I need to hydrate for this
this episode is taking a toll that was
having crossed my mind to pack my bags
and go home hi Chris Lincoln uses his
answer to slam Chris I mean I guess he's
actually debating and then that
translated into Lincoln calling me a and
Becca is over the drama and I don't
blame her and I also want to come out
drown how great she looked during this
episode Becca could be a gorgeous wife
of a politician or wait for it a
gorgeous politician herself any day of
the week but the problem is Becca's over
the drama and I don't blame her because
the dramas stupid but this drama is all
the drama we have so that's the catch-22
that were in you know who wins the
debate no one because everybody loses
when it's not fun to watch it's all too
minor I don't want to watch them bicker
with each other over stupidity that has
nothing to do with Becca and everything
to do with nothing so redemption
productions this is a huge herd em
someday though Chris is worried about
redeeming himself redemption which yeah
you know it's a lost cause at this point
Chris just call it a day Becca's there's
no way Becca's into him at this point
she's not you know she's not you can
tell so tell me how have you been how
are you feeling then we're at the later
portion of the date and Chris is gonna
try to talk to Becca and Chris you know
I wish that you were as solid as your
hair and I wish that you were as open as
the ripped holes in your jeans and I
wish that you were as tried and true as
that large arm tattoo but you're not go
home it's time oh and poor Garrett you
know we've barely seen him this episode
either and Becca's trying to talk to him
and he's not wearing the best shirt I've
ever seen him wear but fact it's just so
mad at Chris and again this is the
problem it's like Becca is getting
affected by this drama that is not even
good drama if this was a scripted show
this wouldn't fly guys we would need
something more grounded huh so I don't
know Garrett pulls back out of the hole
and I see a super strong future here
that's what gets me playing with you
guys and then somehow she says she sees
a super strong future with these guys I
guess that's what the guys do we didn't
see much of this episode
I need to get healthy yeah I need to be
revitalized just like this season we're
at a dangerous midpoint I want things to
get better I do I do now Becca is gonna
go on a one-on-one with Leo and on the
one hand great I think he seems fine he
seems nice got a great bod
on the other hand I don't think she's
that into him we haven't really seen
them connect very strong and she's again
all upset from these guys and it's just
like the date that wills had to pull her
out of the dark place on and leo says
hey don't worry we can do nothing yeah
you are please do not do nothing please
do something I need to see something
okay nothing makes a man like some
oyster shucking I guess there's
something that they're gonna do is that
they're gonna shuck oysters which I do
love oysters and they have some
champagne and that's nice
but it's still not very glamorous is it
I don't mean to contradict myself I know
that I've said in the past that I want
to see them do like normal things on
dates to get really connected but if
you're gonna put somebody in the water
have it be on a cool boat you know I
don't know I mean they're gone they're
not gonna make their living shucking
oysters together in Virginia so what are
we learning here but Leo can lift her up
in a boat that's the TV we watched
tonight you guys what do you guys think
of Leo and Becca's connection she says
she felt a spark but acknowledge that
it's too late in the game is there any
chance here let me know the comments
okay now we're back to Chris Oh drink
every time you need a break
and Chris is like writing something
dramatically I don't know why cuz I
don't think we ever see what he writes I
definitely forgot Connor was here we get
a little bit of Connor okay
then Chris puts on a watch dramatically
what is this leading up to is it a spy
movie now
I don't know and Leo we're back to Leo
and Becca and he says to Becca quote you
should never have a bad day ever what
what we've got to be more grounded and
we've got to be more glamorous I need
grounded moments I need glamorous
moments I don't want Easter shocking
moments I don't want stupid squabbling
moments I want grounded and I want glam
in depth and fantastical I'm making a
show sound really extreme but that's
what I want it's all to middling at this
point okay so Chris goes to see Becca on
his own and he keeps saying this is
crazy what are you doing here like this
is crazy it's not really you chose to
come here back to sleep what are you
doing here so what is he doing there
he's there to talk to you and then he
keeps saying about our hotel room this
is nice it's not nice it's not that nice
of a hotel room
Chris stop grasping at straws just let
it go where you guys is over this by
this point as me like did you think
Chris had any hope or any chance I have
so many questions of red flags now that
I don't know if we can get there I don't
think we can at this point
Becca finally acknowledges what we all
have seen which is that it is time for
Chris to Kris Kringle his way out of
here and leave your time is up Christmas
is over and it wasn't that fun so Chris
is leaving and she's like I'm gonna walk
you out cuz I always walk him out and
he's like don't walk me out and she's
like I'm gonna you deserve it I'm gonna
give you that response he's like I don't
want it and we're still squabbling I
can't
let's we've got to stop the squabbling
Oh Becca finally puts a nail in that
coffin and says of Chris quote somebody
ever you know he's gonna be fun to watch
on mental wall and by fun I mean
unhinged okay we kind of skipped through
a rose ceremony Becca wasn't into it and
we said goodbye Lincoln and goodbye
Connor take a picture it'll last longer
because they were the guys who did the
picture frame thing the beginning of
season remember that have we gone too
far down a dark hole mm-hmm that we've
got to pull back out of next week The
Bachelorette dear lord I think we're
going to have some Redemption Redemption
Redemption Redemption day we are going
to the Bahama collar blues and yellows
breathe
flowers beach bods cocktails boats that
aren't for oyster-shucking and involving
waiters I was close to the end I mean I
wish I could be like Jesus right now and
turn this water into wine because man do
I want it mmm we've got to stay healthy
and stay strong because this is the
midpoint of the season you guys so we
got not only a lot of bright colors in
this trailer but a lot of interesting
aesthetics also Blake's palm tree or
maybe banana leaf prints black and white
t-shirt I just want to call that out
Jason looking like a priest in a black
tea with a cross combined with that
slicked back hair he is just a cast
member in the departed and gold and of
course in another hoodie a sleeveless
one because the Bahamas what do you
think of who Becca is going to choose at
this point Blake's been kind of behind
the scenes for a minute I think we're
gonna get a little more of him next
episode Garrett seems to be getting a
little frustrated by not getting more
time with Becca he really wanted that
rose this week and then we've got you
know wills who has been kind of slow and
steady Leo I'm not sure it's there and
oh god forget why I do that
so everybody
let me know where your head's at
just mine's little all over the place
and how you're feeling about the season
overall are you liking it are you
turning on it are you hoping for the
best
I love you guys so much and no matter
what you make the show fun to watch
every week I really appreciate your
comments always always always and please
feel free to DM me on Instagram too
because not really brighten the day
especially when my day included an
allergic reaction to my face thank you
for being you